Well,
that's the sun devouring father,
that's a painting by Medina of Satan.
It's pretty horrifying one,
and that's Captain Hook.
I really liked the figure of Captain
Hook some of these popular mythological
stories.
Myths based fairytales.
Modern fairy tales have got things
really right.
Captain Hook.
Well,
he's a pirate.
So I think I told you that in the Google
engineers investigations of female
sexual fantasies,
the pirate played a large role werewolf
vampire pirate surgeon,
billionaire credibly comic comical,
well pirate,
you know,
captain of the high seas and someone
willing to break rules.
There's a romance in that figure.
Well,
so the idea of the great father as the
pirate is a good one.
Well,
Kirk is kind of a pathetic pirate and of
course pirates are precisely that
because they're all crooked.
And so what makes empathetic?
Well it isn't because he's got a hook
precisely because maybe that's just a
sign of adventure.
It's because he's being chased by a
crocodile with a clock in its stomach.
Well,
that's the dragon of chaos right now.
It's time,
tick,
tick.
Your life is going to end.
It's already got a piece of you and it's
coming for the rest,
and so the hook is terrified of that.
He's terrified into resentment and and,
and evil,
roughly speaking,
why he can prey on other people.
And so that's the father in the Peter
Pan Story out in Neverland,
which is the archetypal domain captain
Hook's the farther,
well,
why would peter pan want to grow up to
be Captain Hook?
Well,
he doesn't,
and so he stays.
Pan.
Pan Means everything,
right?
Like pantheism,
he stays everything.
He's this divine child.
He never wants to grow up.
Well,
why would you sacrifice the potential of
youth to become nothing but a death
obsessed tyrant?
Well,
that's the story in,
in Peter Pan,
and of course Wendy's in the story,
and so as Tinkerbell,
tinkerbell is the imagined feminine.
She's.
She doesn't even exist.
She's just this perfect little thing
that's always around whenever Peter Pan
needs her.
But the problem with Tinkerbell is that
she's a fairy and fairies don't exist.
He has wendy there.
She's a real girl.
When she grows up and actually marry
someone,
Peter Pan Stays King of the lost boys
forever and you know,
maybe it's better to be king of the lost
boys,
but not to be king it all,
but maybe not to king of the dam does
not exactly something to.
It's not a dominance hierarchy to strive
for dominating.
So that's the Peter Pan Story and it's a
right.
It's the right story for the modern age,
that's for sure.
So that's a negative element of the
great father.
Here's the positive element of the great
father.
These are both read.
This is a representation of Moses
receiving the the rules for living from
God on high.
What we talked about that already know,
and I see that that's a story of the
revelation of structure.
That's the story of we're acting out a
moral structure.
Well,
what is it now?
And then we get a glimpse of what the
moral structure isn't.
It hits people with the force of a
revelation,
then it can be articulated,
and that's partly what the story of
Moses lays out.
When you see here,
this picture,
I really liked this one too.
This is a supplicant,
basically someone who's who's hit hard
by a divine vision.
It's God in heaven.
Again,
very,
very similar to this with with the cross
in the background and it's something
like that to transcend your littleness
because look,
he's looking up.
That's what's at the top of the
dominance hierarchy is what at the top
of all possible dominance hierarchies.
Look up.
That's the father who supports the
sudden,
that's transcending his own
vulnerability,
right?
Willing to bear it voluntarily and not
too,
and not to shirk from that.
It's exactly right and it is what you
admire in people who you admire,
people who are courageous and who were
strong,
and when you decompose that,
it means that they're able to act
appropriately and in a helpful,
compassionate,
wise and tough manner.
Despite the fact that there'd be set
with all of the problems of mortality
than everyone else.
Well,
how does it go wrong?
that's whole propaganda for Hitler.
Look at the imagery.
You know,
he's a night that's on the right.
He's the.
He's the night of nationalism.
Well,
that's God the father too.
You know it's a little bit one sided,
right,
because there's more to the farther than
the state.
That's the thing,
and that's the problem with nationalism
and it's totalitarian variance and we're
moving into that direction fast,
right?
You see Europe right now fragmenting
again because the European Union is too
amorphous and maybe not well enough
bordered and everyone is getting nervous
and they're saying back to the state,
back to the state,
it's fair enough.
Fair enough.
You.
You need to be around people who are
like you,
so to speak,
that you have built a consensus with,
but to subordinate yourself to the state
and to make its head that the bearer of
the,
the archetype of the night without
having that element of individuality and
it is absolutely pathological.
We've already been down that road,
right?
Because the national socialists were
hyper national,
just like,
oh it both in Germany and in Italy and
it's attractive.
Again,
it's interesting here you see Hitler as
a night and up here there's a bird,
you know,
and that bird should be the dove because
that should be the holy ghost if the
iconography was proper,
but it's not.
It's an eagle and an eagle is a bird of
carrion eater,
right?
It feeds on corpses while it's worth
thinking about.
So that's the woman worshiping the
strong father.
Another representation of Hitler as a
night,
and then there's Hitler as wise father
is.
He is surrounded by people there who
focused in on him as if he's an
architect.
Archetype will import and then this is a
poster from,
from the allies,
Nancy Nazi poster from allies,
and you see right there that Hitler and
the Nazis are assimilated to a massive
predatory snakes.
It's like,
well,
why?
Well,
if you want to appeal to someone's
determination to destroy you say,
well here you are in.
You're already to go.
Let's go kill some snakes.
And everyone can say yes,
and then you say,
well there's the snakes right there.
And the thing is,
it's true to some degree because you,
you have plenty of snakes.
Just like everyone else,
and so it's easy.
That's the first step towards
demonization and you can do it just like
that.
It's no problem.
The archetype will map perfectly,
especially if there's already tension
between the groups or if the other group
is identifiable in some manner or you
can make it identifiable.
Discussed is the best way to do that,
not fear,
disgust,
fear to fear someone.
You have to respect them.
You don't want to burn everything that
the person that you fear owns.
You want to burn everything that the
person who disgusts you owns,
and so you'll see people who are pushing
the nationalist agenda hard and Hitler
did this beautifully.
Everything that was outside of the area
and domain of purity wasn't to be
feared.
It was disgusting.
It was contemptuous and it should be
destroyed and purified by fire,
and that was his message.
The Nazis were unbelievably great at
using fire of purification as a symbolic
message.
Well,
it has an archetype will power.
Then you see here,
this is an English,
a poster from the World War II.
I'm asking people to buy bonds to fund
the American or the British war effort,
and you see these,
these talon like plause Japan and Nazi
Germany reaching out to the virgin
mother and her infant child,
right?
The deep use of deep subordination,
of archetipal imagery for the purposes.
While I hesitate to say propaganda
because World War II in some sense was
pretty clear cut,
but you,
you get the point and there's the
uniform reoccur.
That uniformity of the state,
right?
So the goose step,
everybody moves exactly the same way.
Everybody's put.
Everybody's turned into exactly the same
carbon copy of everyone else.
All the diversity is pushed out of the
state.
It's subordinated to the supreme leader
in the hierarchy becomes incredibly
rigid and,
and,
and homogenous.
So like,
well,
that's great for fast action,
but it's terrible if you don't know
where you're going,
you need some diversity,
needs some flaws in the crystalline
structure in case you're on the wrong
path.
And that's why you can't have everyone
being the supreme leader's acolytes.
The whole bloody thing wanders off in
one direction and because we don't know
the right direction to go wandering off
in a single direction is extraordinarily
dangerous.
You will eventually fall over a cliff,
so there's the Nazis use of of light at
night.
There were unbelievably good out there
at.
There is one of the things that made
fascism so difficult to fight because
with communism,
because it was a fully articulated
philosophy,
you could attack it rationally,
but fascism never really did that.
What they did instead was used ritual,
right?
Huge mass rallies and highly emotionally
supercharged meetings and then the use
of light and fire and so Hitler built
the biggest parade grounds in human
history to host the Nuremberg rallies
and he would get in front of them on
this huge stage with with Greek columns.
Very impressive looking and have blocks
of thousands of people organized
perfectly orderly.
The Germans are good at order in order
is associated with disgust,
sensitivity,
incredibly organized,
orderly displays complete and then at
night with fire and behind him he would
have all of the search lights from the
Luftwaffe,
aligned up dozens of them shooting their
light straight up miles into the sky.
So we stand in front of these incredibly
impressive displays of light.
Long before there were rock shows and so
forth doing that,
you know,
it was unparalleled in history and,
and addressed the crowd and it was very
good at addressing the crowd.
He'd say something and if people were
listening he'd say more of it and if
they were listening you'd say more of
it.
And because he was addressing the mob,
the mob God exactly from Hitler what
they wanted,
and we saw what that was like,
right?
One hundred and $20 million people dead
in no time flat and the worst horrors
that were ever perpetrated on people.
Maybe because there's no shortage of
perpetrated horrors.